so what is the nutritional profile on
this Pizza Karen
well Eric this pizza is very healthy
Scott no flour got love got good stuff
as toasty
[Music]
hey guys we're back in in this video
we're gonna do a part two version of the
last pizza recipe now why are we doing
another pizza video recipe can because
you made the pizza even better oh my
gosh this and you're wearing an apron
that's right so here's the thing there's
a couple little tweaks that we're going
to show you how to make number one you
need to get a pizza stone you need to
heat it about 20 minutes after it hits
450 then you slide it in there so the
bottom part of this crust becomes very
very nice yeah because here's a big
mistake that people are making they're
baking the crust putting all the top on
and then stick it in the oven as one you
have to bake the crust first then put
the top on and re bake it okay
the tops you know all that little stuff
you know I like it so then also a couple
of the points don't put a lot of cheese
on the top part of it and don't put a
lot of sauce just a little bit and then
you know I like the mushroom the
pepperoni the olives
can we taste it okay yeah let's let's
taste this and then make sure after you
taste it
you put it back on the point right
always immediately taste it and then put
it back down that's mmm we learned that
this is like the real deal
it's really good I would add chili
pepper flakes cuz I like hot pepper but
the crust is the key mm-hmm is
everything it's not soggy it's thin
crusted so check out how to make this
but your comments below
is there any flour in this absolutely
zero flour is it nutritional absolutely
nutritious
yes ingredients are hormone free organic
cheese nitrates we don't do vegan
recipes I mean occasionally we may but
by and large that's not
gonna be the recipe so this isn't vegan
but it's really really really good right
check it out
you
[Music]
Oh give it up crazy route cut that out
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video